- So when I first got
into self-improvement,
I had really bad social anxiety.
Talking to somebody I
didn't know very well,
especially if they were a girl,
was really difficult for me.
Even carrying on a basic
human conversation was
something that I didn't really
know how to do very well.
I'd always be stuck in
my head thinking about
what I was gonna say next,
and worrying about whether
they were impressed with me.
And I also didn't have very many friends.
People didn't really invite me anywhere.
So I started searching on
Reddit for answers, you know,
kind of lurking through
self-improvement subreddits
like I used to do quite
a bit back in the day.
And there was a book recommendation
that kept on coming up
in every single self-improvement
subreddit that I looked at.
It seemed to be everyone's go-to book
they would recommend for people struggling
with social anxiety or
struggling with being able
to maintain a basic conversation.
And that book was "How to Win
Friends and Influence People"
by Dale Carnegie.
It came as kind of a shock
to me because this book was
published in 1936.
In 2019, it's closer to the year 2100
than it is to when that
book was published,
yet in 2011, TIME magazine ranked it
as the 19th most influential
book in American history.
So it doesn't mess around.
So I was starting to get
this vibe that it was
the bible of human communication,
and I gave it a read
and it changed my life.
I'm not saying that this
book was responsible
for everything good that
ever happened in my life
or anything like that.
But what I do mean is that
it changed my perspective.
And I learned some things from this book
that I have carried with me to this day,
I've never forgotten and
they've completely transformed
the way I interact with people,
having conversations
with pretty much anybody
is not an issue for me anymore,
and people actually invite me to stuff.
So I'm gonna go over some of
the most impactful lessons
from the book, "How to Win
Friends and Influence People"
and hopefully it helps you out
as much as it helped me out.
Just to preface before
I dive into these tips,
or these lessons or whatever
you want to call them,
they are just tools.
All these things I'm about
to say are just tools.
They're not absolute
rules. They can be broken.
But that being said, they
are very powerful tools
that I think work extremely
well in most situations,
especially this first one
that I'm about to dive into.
It's less of a tip or a tool,
it's more like a paradigm shift
that you can apply to pretty
much your entire philosophy
when it comes to dealing with people.
And that is lesson one,
it's all about the other person.
It may come as no surprise to you
that everyone basically just
thinks about themselves.
What they've got going on in their lives,
what they want to eat for dinner,
what are they stressing about,
what they want to do tomorrow,
the vacation they want
to take next summer.
They're not really
thinking about you at all.
You probably wouldn't be surprised
to find out that you primarily
think about yourself as well.
And when you think about other people,
it's always in the context of you.
It's like, "Does this person like me?
Do they think I'm stupid
because I said this thing?"
It's always about you.
Everyone else thinks that exact same way.
So in order to become better with people,
you have to realize this
and see things from other
people's perspective.
People's favorite hobby and
people's favorite topic,
and the one they're most
comfortable talking about
is things to do with themselves.
So if you want to become
a good conversationalist,
you have to become an
investigator in people,
try to get them talking about
what's going on in their lives
and you will never run
out of conversation,
which people sort of know,
but they don't practice
it because they feel like
they're not getting anything
out of the interaction,
you know, by entirely focusing
on what the other person
has going on in their life, you know,
you're almost stepping on
yourself and not allowing
your own personality to
shine or something like that.
But I found kind of the opposite is true.
When you become genuinely
interested in other people
and what they have going on in their life,
they're a lot more likely
to return the favor.
A lot of people have been in
a situation or a conversation
where somebody starts
talking about their dreams
and their ambitions and their skills
and things they've done.
And then the other person just
responds with their dreams
and their ambitions and the
things that they want to do.
And they sort of just start,
it's like a back and forth,
they're trying to one up each other,
and nobody really gets anything
out of the conversation,
no one's really listening.
They're just focusing on basically,
you know what measuring.
But when you actually listen to the person
talk about their ambitions
and their skills,
and you genuinely ask
them pressing questions
about what their
motivation was behind this,
what they think they got out
of it, et cetera, et cetera,
and you actually practice
being genuinely curious,
not only would that person
really appreciate the fact
that you're actually
asking genuine questions
and that you're listening,
they're way more likely to
ask you genuine questions
about yourself.
And you can generate a pretty
close friendship very quickly.
So next time you dive into a
conversation with somebody new,
genuinely try to be an
investigator in what is going on
in their life.
What is making them tick
and try to get to know them
and actually listen.
Lesson number two, make them feel valued.
Now, before I dive into this tip,
I just want to say something.
A lot of people think that this book,
"How to Win Friends and Influence People",
and these tips that I'm giving,
and the tips that are
available in the book,
that they're somehow manipulative.
I don't see that as true.
They're only manipulative
if you use them to manipulate somebody.
Giving somebody a genuine compliment,
or even if you make it a habit
to give someone a genuine
compliment only does good.
Putting somebody in a good mood
by complimenting their
appearance, a personality trait,
or something that you
genuinely find good about them
often makes their day and they walk around
the office or town or
whatever they're doing
with a kind of swagger in their step.
All because you complimented
on something that you noticed
that you liked about them.
One of the greatest ways you
can make people feel valued
is to use their name and use it liberally.
"Hey Joey, how's it going?"
"Oh, hey Joey." "Hey
guys, look, it's Joey."
That makes me feel great
when people use my name,
especially if they
don't know me very well,
or if I just met them maybe one time
and they remembered my
name, that makes my day,
like it makes me feel valued,
it makes me feel like
they actually remembered
our conversation,
even though they probably didn't.
By using somebody's name,
it makes people feel like
you have a connection,
just instantly.
The second way to make people feel valued
is to give genuine compliments.
Once you start practicing
empathy and start practicing
seeing things from another
person's perspective,
like the book is all about,
then you'll get really
good at noticing things
that stand out from person to person.
And once you get in the habit
of vocalizing those things,
you'll become somebody who
people gravitate towards,
and people just really like being around.
Once you start to become
an investigator in people,
you can really start
to psychoanalyze people
and compliment them on
their actual personality.
Complimenting someone's
personality is often
way more powerful than just
complimenting something
that's hanging off their body, a necklace,
or that sounded like, that's a weird,
telling somebody that they're
"An extremely good listener
and I really appreciate it"
is a lot more powerful than saying,
"I like your shirt."
Before our final tip,
just a quick word from
today's video sponsor,
Tiege Hanley.
Okay, so I decided to reshoot this ad
because I'm noticing even more benefits
of using Tiege Hanley on my skin.
So for those of you who don't know,
Tiege Hanley is a skin care system for men
designed to take the
complication out of good skin.
Every single month,
they ship you four different
components to your door.
Number one is the wash, which
you can use in the shower.
That's what I do.
Number two is the scrub,
which you use twice a week,
also in the shower.
And after your shower,
if it's the morning you
use the AM moisturizer.
And if it happens to be at
night after your shower,
you use the PM moisturizer.
As you've been watching this channel,
you've probably noticed
I don't have the greatest skin genetics.
So I've never had like beautiful skin,
but I'm getting closer
thanks to Tiege Hanley.
You guys have probably heard
me talk about the slight edge
or the compound effect
where simple daily habits
that don't seem to do a lot
equal a huge success later down the road.
One area of my life where
that's been abundantly clear
is my skincare routine
thanks to Tiege Hanley.
Better Ideas viewers get
20% off their first box,
so click the link below
if you want to take advantage of that deal
or just use the coupon code
"Better Ideas" at check out,
and yeah, I hope you
enjoy it as much as I do.
Okay guys, so take a
look at this scene from
"The Great Gatsby."
I didn't even really like
this movie very much,
but this is one scene that
I remember as clear as day,
and I watched this like three years ago.
This is the scene where Spider
Man meets Leonardo DiCaprio.
I forget the characters' names.
Look at the way this interaction goes.
- You see...
I'm Gatsby.
- Oh, you're...
(grand music)
His smile was one of those rare smiles
that you may come across
four or five times in life.
It seemed to understand
you and believe in you,
just as you would like to be
understood and believed in.
- Sorry, old sport, I thought you knew.
- Please just, I don't know
what to say. Please forgive me.
- It's quite all right.
- [Nick] I've had so much to drink.
- Mr. Gatsby, sir, Chicago (indistinct).
- I'll be just a minute.
I'm taking my new hydroplane
out in the morning.
Would you like to go with me?
- What time?
- A time that suits you.
- When he meets Gatsby for the first time,
he feels like there is
understanding behind his smile.
As powerful as Gatsby is,
he still took the time to
put his hand on his shoulder,
look him in the eye,
and really pay attention
and focus on what Peter Parker was saying.
So the last tip is focus.
Pretend that the person in front of you
is the only person in the entire world.
And this channel is all about focus.
The skill of focus translates well
to human interaction as well.
If you learn to minimize your cell phone
and social media use,
if you learn to focus
on slower pace things
and really honing in on
things you find boring,
even boring conversations,
then you'll be able to
make people feel valued
and appreciated and listened to.
That's all that people want.
Even when they go on long
spiels about all their goals
and ambitions, all they want to hear is
"That is incredible."
You know? "Good for you."
So why not make somebody's day by actually
even pretending that you care?
Sometimes that's all people need.
They just need somebody who
pretends like they care.
Bonus points if you
actually learn to care.
So guys, these are just some
of the lessons I learned
from "How to Win Friends
and Influence People"
by Dale Carnegie.
I'll put a link in the description
for you to pick up your copy on Amazon.
I'm not going to make it an affiliate link
or anything like that.
It's probably pretty cheap
if you have an e-reader
like a Kindle or Kobo,
you can probably find it
online, like an online PDF
if you just Google
"HowtoWinFriendsandInfluencePeople.PDF".
If you like this video,
make sure to hit like,
because when you like it,
the algorithm knows that
it's a high quality video
and it helps people see the video.
If you're lurking here and
you haven't subscribed,
hit that subscribe button
and then hit that bell icon
so you don't miss future uploads.
If you have any suggestions for videos
you want me to cover in the future,
let me know in the comments section below.
That's all for today.
Thank you for watching and we'll catch you
in the next video.